ايقظ الصراع العسكري الدائر في العاصمه
السودانيه الخرطوم ومحيطها صراعا اخر عمره
عقدان في الغرب البعيد من البلاد منطقه
دارفور
دارفور الواقعه في اقصى الغرب السوداني
تحظى بولاياتها الخمس باهميه استراتيجيه
كبيره لطرفي الصراع المتحاربين في السودان
فالاقليم يتشارك حدوديا مع اربع دول من
الغرب تشاد وليبيا ومن الجنوب افريقيا
الوسطى وجنوب السودان تسكن المنطقه قبائل
عده عربيه وافريقيه وسط وفره في الثروه
الزراعيه والحيوانيه والمعادن منذ اندلاع
القتال بين الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريع منتصف ابريل تفاوت حجم العنف في
انحاء دارفور حيث تعرضت نيالا جنوب دارفور
والفاشر في الشمال لقتال عنيف في الايام
الاولى من الصراع لينحسر القتال فيهما
تدريجيا في الايام الاخيره ولينتقل بشده
وعنف الى مدينه الجنينه متسببا بمقتل ما
لا يقل عن 100 مدني وفق الامم المتحده
ومنظمات الاغاثه ونجد الاهتمام الدولي
يتركز اليوم على دارفور التي شهدت نزاعات
قبليه قديمه ومتكرره حيث يظهر فراغ امني
كبير يخشى مراقبون من ان يؤدي الى حرب
اهليه
خاصه مع تزايد التسليح بين المدنيين
وافراد القبائل المتناحره عدا عن اعمال
النهب والتدمير واضرام الحرائق في المنازل
والمباني الحكوميه هذا فضلا عن مخاوف من
ان تلجا قوات الدعم السريع الى الاحتماء
في حاضنتها هناك اذا تازمت الامور في باقي
الولايات لتشتعل الامور اكثر في الاقليم
كل هذه تطورات دفعت الالاف من السكان
المحليين الى الفرار الى تشاد المجاوره
والى جمهوريه افريقيا الوسطى بكل متاعهم
فيما يبدو وكانه رحيل بلا عوده
ملوك الشيخ العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات